what do you make of Howard Stern
slamming assignment on his radio show
it's the way he feels I agree with a lot
of it how is it that that freak Simon
Cowell
has orchestrated this he has set it up
at the men's stay no matter how old they
are no matter how fat they are no matter
how ugly they are you know Simon owns
the show he can do whatever he wants
this is the ultimate example of a boys
club it's a boys club there's new
celebrity backlash against igt today and
it's from two former judges the talks
Sharon Osbourne with et today and Howard
Stern who slammed Simon Cowell on his
Sirius XM show what he manages to do on
all the shows is he constantly replaces
the hot chicks with hotter chicks and
younger chicks which is so obvious I
thought there'd be more complaining from
Mel B and Heidi in Tyra Banks all this
after Julianne Hough and Gabrielle Union
were let go reportedly fired after
Gabrielle complained about a racially
insensitive joke told by Jay Leno and
overall toxic culture at AGT and Simon
smoking on set did he smoke on set it's
I'm smoke of course Simon smokes on set
he probably is the only one I've ever
worked with that that smokes in a
building or wherever he wants it's Simon
it hates you
he can set himself on fire et has
learned Gabriele is expected to meet
with NBC and a gt's production companies
this week you put everybody on notice
we're told she has no interest in
returning to the show but wants to help
make positive changes Gabrielle is gonna
meet with producers would advice do you
have for her hey she's got to stick to
the way she feels and if she feels that
she wasn't treated well and respectfully
that's her journey and that's her story
but some analysts say there's another
factor to consider in all of this the
ratings and a need to shake things up
this past summer America's Got Talent
lost a quarter of its target audience
the steepest ratings drop in the show's
13-year history Simon always likes to
have
who's ever hot at that time on his panel
and I don't think it served him well in
the past
[Music]